لواء عريقات نبدا من خان يونس واسالك عن
ما الذي نفهمه من هذه او هذا الانسحاب
للجيش العسكري من بعض المناطق من خانيونس
يعني هذا تفسير لمقاله جلنت وزير الحرب
حينما قال نحن نفكك استخدام كلمه تفكيك
هذه كلمه يعني ليست موجوده في المصطلحات
العسكر او القاموس العسكري هذه مصطلح
اسرائيلي وهي بالتاكيد تراجع عن الهدف
الاصلي وهو القضاء على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه نحن نعلم انه في 2710 حينما
اجتاحت اربع فرق عسكريه اي 120 الف جندي
اسرائيلي قطاع غزه جاءت بهدفين القضاء على
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحرير الاسر بالقوه
العسكريه اليوم بعد مرور 120 يوم يتحدث
جلنت مع الانسحابات انسحابات الالويه
وانسحابات
الكتائب والوحدات
العسكريه يقول عن التفكيك اذا هو لخص لخص
المشهد
العسكري بمعنى انه فشل في تحقيق الهدف
الاساس ومعروف بالعلم العسكري يمكن تعديل
الخطط العسكريه تبعا لوقائع الميدان لكن
لا يمكن تعديل الاهداف الا اذا حققت الهدف
الاساس الهدف الاساس هو القضاء على
المقاومه اما تفكيك كتائب يعني يتحدث
اليوم وزير حرب وزير الجيش الذي لا يقهر
عن تفكيك كتيبه خان يونس اذا نحن نتحدث عن
تراجع في الاهداف وهذا طبعا ناتج عن تراجع
بالكفاءه القتاليه للجنود الاسرائيليين
وعدم قدرتهم على تحقيق الاهداف وتدني في
روحهم المعنويه والخسائر الكبيره التي
يمنى بها الجيش الاسرائيلي في كل يوم حتى
في الشمال لواء عريقات كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال نفس الشيء
فككنا حماس وا حققنا بعض الاهداف العسكريه
وتم الانسحاب من بعض المناطق رغم ان
المقاومه ما تزال قادره على اداره المعارك
في الشمال هي قادره حتى على اطلاق بعض
الصواريخ كيف يمكن فهم
ذلك منذ اللحظه الاولى اختي العزيزه منذ
اللحظه الاولى لتقدم الدبابات الاسرائيليه
والجنود الاسرائيليين على الارض والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه تشتبك معهم بتكتيكات مختلفه
تتراجع احيانا تنصب لهم كمان احيانا تشتبك
معهم تقنص دباباتهم عن بعد تقصف صواريخ
تقصف
مدفعيه تنفذ عمليات خلف خطوط العدو هذه هي
التكتيكات التي استخدمتها اذا نحن نتحدث
عن مقاومه تعرف ما تريد منذ اليوم الاول
حتى يومنا هذا والمقاومه الفلسطينيه تنفذ
خططها كامله الجيش الاسرائيلي جاء يفترض
ان تكون خطته تقدم تمدد تطويق تطهير لم
يتح لم يتحقق منها سوى مرحلتين يعني
التقدم ومح ومحاوله التمدد حتى محاوله
التمدد المقاومه الفلسطيني حرمه منها يعني
لم لم يكن اي تمدد للجندي الاسرائيلي دون
ان يكون قلقا على حياته ودون ان يكون معه
اشتباكات من المقاومين الفلسطينيين
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن معادله جيش لا يوجد
لديه خطط عسكريه لا يوجد لديه اهداف يمكن
تحقيقها سوى التفكيك طبعا هذه ما سمعناه
اليوم
وطبعا لذلك اضطروا لسحب عدد كبير من
القوات خاصه لواء الكفير ولواء الجولاني
وها هي اليوم لواء 55 واعتقد انه سينسحب
على بقيه الالويه والقوات لانه عدم تحقيق
الاهداف وتراجع الكفاءه القتاليه وتدني
الروح المعنويه عند الجن والضباط لا جدوى
من بقائهم في الميدان وخاصه اذا ما تكبدوا
خسائر
كثيره من بين ما قاله جالانت
بان سننتقل الى رفح برايك ما شكل المعركه
المتوقعه هناك في منطقه عاليه الكثافه
نعلم جيدا ان اعداد كبيره من النازحين
يتواجدون
هناك يعني اولا هناك مليون و300 ال مواطن
ذهبوا الى هناك
بتعليمات من الجيش الاسرائيلي على اساس
انها منطقه امنه هناك تعقيدات هناك حساسيه
للموقف ليس فقط مع الفلسطينيين ليس فقط مع
المقاومه ايضا مع السلطه الفلسطينيه ايضا
مع السلطات المصريه مع الجيش المصري هناك
اتفاقيات
اي هناك يعني
اشكاليات انا بتقديري يعني هم يريدون
التغطيه على انسحابات من خان يونس ومن
الشمال الترويج بانهم سيذهبون الى رفح
ولاحظي اختي العزيزه ان جلنت قرن الذهاب
الى رفح بعد بعد اي تحرير الرهائن او بعد
تبادل الرهائن والاسره كما قال اذا هو
يعني قال سنذهب الى رفح ولكن بعد يعني بعد
بعد ان يكون هناك تبادل فبالتالي يعني
حينما بداوا حربهم البريه كانوا يتوقعون
انهم سيحققون اهداف الشمال وحينما لم
يجدوها توجهوا الى الوسط والى غزه والى
المستشفيات وخاصه مستشفى الشفاء والكل
يعرف القصه قصه مستشفى الشفاء حينما فشلوا
اضطروا الى الذهاب الى
مفاوضات وهدنه بعد الهدنه قالوا سنذهب الى
خانيونس للقضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وتحرير الاسرى لانهم موجودين هناك بعد
شهرين الان في خان يونس لم يجدوا لم يجدوا
لا الاسرى ولم يجد يجدوا المقاومين الان
يريدون ان يقولوا لانهم فشلوا فشلوا في
المراحل الثلاث الاولى يريدوا ان يغطوا
عليها بان رفح فيها انفاق وفيها مقاومه
وفيها اسرى وايضا يريدون توسيع دائره
الاشتباك في المنطقه وربما [__] استفزاز
المصريين لان لا يريد
نتنياهو ان يظهر انه هزم امام المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وامام قطاع غز وامام الشعب
الفلسطيني ويريد ان يشتت يشتت الجهود يشتت
الانظار ويغطي على فشل الجيش الاسرائيلي
برمته